citizens of the reject Nation I'm Tara Erickson
joined by my close to your personal friends I
see your name I'm John oh what's your last
name John's Humphrey oh right I I forgot I
didn't really forget I just wanted him to
see it listen guys we're watching The Maze
Runner from 2014. that's from a long time ago
yeah almost 10 years I did not read the book
I don't think uh if I did I cannot remember it
but we're gonna watch it and it's gonna be fun
so you guys need to leave a like you know what
to do you need to get on the computer type the
words leave a comment and then you also have to
subscribe and by doing that you can bring the Bell
yes also thanks to prepper for adding down
this reaction video and don't forget if
you're not already a patron you should
become one because if you are then you
can sync up with your own copy and watch a
full-length reaction with me and John like
the whole thing where we're sitting we're
reacting we're doing stuff you can watch
it with us with your own very full length
copy and then also we call you super sexy
also Greg and John cover several shows exclusively
over there with highlights and watch alongs in
colluded so like get on the juice come on
now get on the juice okay just do it and
I think that's it should we just like watch
it let's just watch it okay man let's do it
foreign
are we going down or up oh
yes not feeling well it's a Dylan O'Brien
hey that's a guy from Love and
monsters oh and there's a monster
this is how every one of my days begins day
one granny Rising shot Will Poulter oh whoa
hey we gotta run [Applause] a Maze Runner
mayhaps still trying to figure out what
the f is going on oh okay it's their first
day at an all boys high school he's stuck
oh okay was that like the version of hazing that
was their version of hey they're like throw them
in that elevator with that spooky elevator yeah
my name is zombie you tell me anything about
yourself Who You Are where you came from Alby the
racist dragon why can't I remember it it's okay
it happens to us all you get your name back in a
day or two what it's a powerful anesthetic we grow
our own food build our own shelter whatever
we need the Box provides the Box provides
a big old box send them once a month with fresh
supplies in the new Greenie I who though who put
us here and now we don't know green bean no
I love him when I'm not around he's in charge
this is spinach the boy from Love Actually is
so grown up now and I think he's on Game of
Thrones too to be fair oh yeah chojin something
what's up there never gonna be on those walls do
you understand me Greenie yes carrots what happens
behind the walls everybody wants to know hey Chuck
excellent nice these are those same pants haven't
been washed where where are you going I just want
to see kilogram all you want but you better
not go out there I just know what I'm told
I'm not supposed to leave where's
your sense of adventure Chuck he
pooped his pants too many times
he doesn't have Adventures anymore
negrini huh how does it feel to be promoted hey
they were just for outside they break breaking
rules they're different they're Runners they know
more about the maze than anyone what you just said
maze I did oh chuck oh you're done messed up now
chuck chuck doesn't have a vault why won't you
tell me what's out there trying to protect you man
for your own good you guys can't just keep me here
I can't let you leave why not he's doing the Chris
Pratt hand [Laughter] stay where you are blue
oh what
uh awesome I would like to go out
now this is pretty intriguing so far
it's a metaphor crushed by circumstance
welcome to the Glade the Glade or the
blade I still don't know what they're
saying yeah they're interchangeable
sure there are plenty of blades
in the Glade all right bonfires
where'd you get that cow head or horse head or
whatever that is the skull we're trapped here
for the moment how's the runners that
guy in the middle there that's Mina
the coolest one they run the maze
memorizing it trying to find a way
out how long have they been looking
three years oh my God that's too long
but yeah it's amazing changing oh this is some
sick psycho ward they're all watching you yeah
you're all Lab Rats Runners are the only ones
that really know what's out there and it's a
good thing too because if they don't make it back
before those doors close then they're stuck out
there for the night how many of you lost no
one's ever survived the night oh but you will
you got this Dylan O'Brien yeah man you're the
greeny they never saw it coming what happened
or we call them Grievous of course no one's ever
seen one and live to tell about it Grievers good
why a novel terminology no no one wants to be a
runner and besides you don't get chosen if chosen
by who the jerk guy you don't like now fight and
show you're worthy what do you say Greenie wanna
see What You're Made Of yes creamy greeny greeny
greeny greeny greeny the rules are simple Greenie
I'm trying to push you out of the circle
try to last more than five seconds ready
[Applause] he's not doing so hot what do
you want to be called Shank [Applause]
you are too funny I think I'm settled on Shank
it's better than radish that's
what I can get him oh boy nice
now you've done it you've upset the
structure you upset the hierarchy man
Thomas what oh that's my name
I remember my name I'm Thomas
[Music] all right Tommy Boy I've never seen
that either I do love how every single y
novel adaptation does have like a sequence
where they take a break to dump all the new
terminology on you yeah these guys are called
the this and those are called the that yeah
dang
oh that's spooky we lost a lot of boys to fear
Panic we've come far since then established order
why are you telling me this because you're
not like the others and the audience needs
to know that you're curious he was
there for five like five minutes oh oh
no oh boy okay or George they don't even
try and climbing in the top yes anything
you think of we've already tried the only way
out here is through the maze now look you want
to be helpful yes obviously I guess that's some
more fertilizer some late Reflex on that catch
what do we got bones oh great damn
they did not bury that body very well
and George must not have died in The Maze
oh oh he looks so good buddy Ben
right I don't know if we uh ever
what the oh my God what are you
okay what oh damn oh my gosh she's
I saw you your fault what
that's right yes oh no who a
some heavy stunts in this game
not gonna lie this kind of going
hard yeah definitely help what the
fudge oh my goodness oh [Applause]
oh
stung by a griever contact with
a griever he's been stuck in the
middle of the day we gotta put him down
put him in the pit come on everybody
I'm pretty sure he's gonna be able to
break out of that pit I wonder what it
must have been like to be some of the other people
hanging out in the field all day shooting he said
he saw me you know this is all my fault how could
this be my fault let's get some rest what do
you know oh just please listen to me please
man sorry dude that's hardcore
[Music]
they're just gonna like send them out
oh no please please don't please don't
do it oh you're gonna become one of
them buddy you gotta go oh they're
gonna have to push him with those tea
sticks yeah [Music] uh yep here we go
cheese man awkward
just run buddy just go just accept your fate get
out of there you don't want to be squished to
death yeah you're gonna get smushed come
on run oh what are you doing oh my God
oh hey okay so he accepted smooshing as his
fate or uh well he just didn't want to go take
his chances with the maze he's right there okay he
doesn't want to get soft-fived right now you think
he might make it he did survives the night in the
maze you don't know that man yeah you haven't been
out there Chuck oh here we go another dreamy or a
memory oh a memory a lady is that Wicked is good
oh for a second I thought that was
Kirsten Stewart it's not I thought it was
um the one from get out two and Megan or
Kate Mar she looks like a bunch of people
Tunes what do they put in your jeans man
give you some kind of griever repellent Juju
my volunteers tribute why would Aldi go in the
Maze I'll be went to retrace Ben's footsteps
before Sundown so he's gonna go back to where
Ben was just starting he knows what he's doing
he knows better than any of us until he doesn't
come back tonight every month the Box sends up
a new arrival someone had to be first right
it's Alby first that was Alby oh it begins
with a yeah this is the future the feminists
want all the men in one compound can't leave
monsters outside they should be back by now
what happens if they don't make it they're
gonna make it this is what they do it's part
of the show right at the last minute or they
won't and you guys will be worried
all night are they dead or not can't
we send someone after them that's against
the rules can't risk losing anyone else
I mean you're kind of risking losing all
of you by standing at the mouth but yeah
I'm around at the last second here we
go somebody's injured oh no okay hurry
oh God this is a close call uh leave him
go in Dylan O'Brien you have to leave him
so he's gonna help it's all up
to you that greeny's gonna do it
yeah
how are you gonna oh it closed oh dang oh
snap oh my goodness what are they gonna do
what happened to us it looked like
okay he's a Graver now get him up
this is already changing just leave
them here the old rules don't apply
green bean I mean he's dead so
take his vest pack and get going
there's not a single place we can take him
take a look around there's nowhere to go
well I feel like there's a lot of hallways
in a maze around you you just try something
cover him up with the vines or
what are we thinking or climb wow
okay still think it was a really
bad choice not taking his vest off
him and using his weapons yeah
a little bit but if he wakes up
he'll need to defend himself whilst
mortally wounded what are you doing
[Music]
what the all right buddy leave him in a
Lurch yeah he knows the maze yeah he's got
time for this green bean [__] oh is he just
gonna like all right camouflage up in there
oh what is this thing is it What organic or
mechanical yeah it looks metal to me heavy metal
I mean the soundscape alone in here is quite
jarring yeah very freaked out in here [Music]
spooky is it like a spider
looks like a robo spider
oh gross that looks like
a Harry Potter spider yeah
no
I swooping camera movements [Applause] oh Wowie
oh my God online boy oh whoa whoa nice jump oh
how does this work [Music]
s faith
did the same people like engineer these creatures
oh nice
you could be the first two to make it back here
that trust your instincts [Music]
oh yeah what if he like I was thinking that
like what if he just stays in there and then
crushes the spider but he gets out right
on time yeah yeah smart that's what oh god
yeah yeah yeah oh oh oh oh oh good good
good good come on buddy you got this
no way
yeah this is just like yesterday you
saw a griever you can just see it
killed it oh man oh greeny King green beans yeah
for three years we have coexisted with these
things and now you've killed one of them you call
it coexisting he has to be punished what you don't
even know if you're gonna get backlash for the
spider dying yet buddy when I turned tail and ran
this dumb shank stood behind to help Alby look
I don't know if he's Brave or stupid yes both
whatever it is we need more of it I say we
make him a runner yeah now we're talking the
subtle version of one of my favorite tropes we
need more around like that around here you're
hired but if there was one thing that I know
about the maze it is that you do not [Music]
it's moving at a different time right
everything's changing man okay it's
coming back up it should have been uh oh just
Jump Right In what oh oh no oh God no this is
not good is that his mom or something that's the
girl who was in the thing with him in his memory
oh
okay last Greenie the last one ever to oh yeah
she knows who he is my name is also Thomas You're
Gonna Go on dissect that thing all by yourself
I will if I have to the other one who's left yet
the other Runners quit this morning also ask
about where's your vest yeah I'm supposed to
get a vest I think it's time we find out what
we're really up against you're not going back
out there out there looking me in the woods in
half an hour all right man and bring my vest yeah
this be enough okay all right
you got a squad now stepping up
awesome
what oh okay
oh something in there you mean
besides a group of pancake
I take the computer out a camera
that red blinky light is it still
recording all right ready on three one two three
oh that thing's coming okay
what the hell is that
wckd same as on the crate in the elevator oh this
is the same that as we get in our supplies who
knows where this might lead us you see what he's
trying to do right we should punish him oh my God
Mike's freaking guy put this guy in the pit the
rules are the only thing that have ever held us
together why now are we questioning that and kept
you in this big box too starting from tomorrow
you're a runner I mean it seems like the logical
conclusion he's the first one to kill a Graver
and he came back with Clues like why are you so
mad bro yeah like just go cook dinner and chill
it's unprecedented circumstances man come on yeah
like at least a little flexibility from you yeah
Beckham eighth of the way not
at all we must be punished
please tell me there's like an
initiation ayahuasca ceremony
oh my gosh I think you're right what is this thing
oh that's what they've carved all the sequences
of the maze then maybe the the letters and the
numbers is the sequence of the Maze and how
to get out I think maybe or not I don't know
no you're right what do you mean all of it
I thought you were still mapping it there's
nothing left to map hmm oh why haven't you
told anyone this it was obvious call people
needed to believe we had a chance of getting
out but maybe now we do we have a real chance
printing on the walls sections one through eight
when the maze changes it opens up a new section
the pattern always stays the same okay and that
one's from Seven that's so special about seven
last night when you killed that griever section
seven was open tomorrow you and I are going to
take a closer look yeah with Seth Meyers those
are awesome girls are awesome it's true one more
of those things I don't think she likes us very
much hey look we just want to talk we got a hell
of rocks up there yeah like where'd she get
all those racks okay I'm gonna come up okay
hmm just me he's gonna explode yeah stay back
buddy is there nothing this green bean can't do
where am I this is all normal yeah we've all been
through this your name that'll come back to you
in a couple of days it's like this the one thing
that's true oh yeah just like she remembered you
she got it quick girls mature faster are you sure
you don't remember anything else I remember water
feeling like I was drowning these faces staring at
me do you remember that too Thomas woman's voice
saying the same thing over and over Wicked is Good
Wicked is good she's from Boston she's just trying
to explain the slang Wicked is good you were there
there we go these were in my pocket when I came up
a T Virus Wicked is good maybe it's an antidote
for a reason for when you get stung we don't even
know what this stuff is we don't know who sent
it why it came up here with you I mean for all
we know that this thing could kill it well
I mean look at him how could this possibly
make it any worse don't accidentally prick
yourself oh my God you better stab him quick
oh my God hurry up Jesus goodness gracious
oh what do you got there oh that came out
pretty damn big oh that's what he's been
carving the whole time it's for my parents
you remember your parents must have them it
could be a test tube baby why would you give
this to me grandma my best friend maybe if you
find a way out you can give it some for me this
kid's a good actor I want to Chuck a lot me too
I want you to give that to them yourself when
we get out of here we're gonna get out of here
all of us I promise oh buddy big day Greenie sure
you don't want to sit this one out get me in here
no he got a vest where did the vest come
from how was it not a big event how did we
not have a vest event there's a whole deleted
scene where they build the vest they pour some
kind of molten leather into a you know a
big old mold I am upset that would have
been maybe one of the best scenes I know it's
okay maybe it'll be a flashback in part two
or section four all right this is looking
cool I mean no numbers we need to get to seven
all right Z One strange
seven is not supposed to be open for another
week someone's updated the algorithm what
oh it's like activating Geiger counters
I think it's your honest away like it's way back
home to charge it must return to
the charging dock [Music] okay
hey WC whatever it was up there the loading hanger
or something it said it's just another day [Music]
about that oh my God is the hanger gonna move now
whoa cool so do you have to kill all
the Grievers and collect all eight
dang
uh okay who's going in the hole
Quavers
what the [__] oh it's scanning he's gonna be
like no but maybe because they have that thing
give me the whip I'll throw you the
item okay oh okay seven is now closing
[Music]
oh
nice job [Music] oh whoa
right yes good okay oh [Music] wait this is
like breaking up concrete which like this
this doesn't happen all the time no they're
gonna have to completely redraw their map now
whoa oh my God no this is terrible
oh no thank you okay are we done yet
who are they expound yeah come on man what's
going on I still doors they aren't closing
oh now they want y'all to go out there
they're trying to shake stuff up oh or
that means all the Grievers can get in now
if they come out at night it's grief would
come out at night uh grief is coming out at
night oh oh snap okay new entrance multiple
[Music]
all right now y'all are sitting ducks if they can
come from every sector you gotta fight them off
what oh my God y'all better hurry come
on now Teresa can stop them oh man
oh [Applause] everybody
oh yeah select yourself in the old cage
oh
my goodness
I would start lighting stuff on fire and see
if that works burn the place to the ground yeah
whoa holy to Molly oh my God you gotta
throw a fire stick in its mouth yes
yes yes molotovic that's right Theresa
you got great ideas me and you girl girls
get it done that's what I'm talking about
like some stuff on fire [Music] behind me
oh my gosh it's like also a scorpion
yeah
oh good job they stuck it with stuff
[Music]
oh I mean it was bound to happen oh no Chuck not
Chuck Anyone But Chuck you better get him back
somebody stab that piece of metal with something
else yeah come on y'all yeah yeah get it Abby
what's he gonna do yeah pull that cord come on
bro yes go out yes yes kill that hunk of metal
yeah yeah feel the rate
oh [Music] my goodness
Galley oh my God this freaking guy yep he's
one of them one of them and they set him here
what happened before you got here maybe he's right
Thomas stab yourself with it I need to remember
Teresa what are you gonna do to remember
that's got to bring up some weird feelings
put it we don't know are they all
actually there or is it a simulation
the Patricia Arquette
[Music]
did he program this whole thing God he's taking
control he said we had a choice either join him
or banish the Sundown with you excellent It's not
a prison it's a test it all started when we were
kids they'd give us these challenges they were
experimenting on us no the people who put you
here I worked with them the entire time you've
been here I was on the other side of it that
is so Grim why would they send us up if we were
with them is the people we were before the maze
they don't even exist anymore these creators took
care of that and you must have done something to
make them put you in here you went into the
Maze and you found a way out if I hang Albi
would still be alive sacrificed [__] happens
man but I know that if he were here he would
be telling you the exact same thing pick your ass
up and finish what you started oh I'll be here in
spirit what if Thomas is right maybe he can lead
us home we are home I'd love it here you really
think Vanishing us is going to solve anything this
isn't a banishing it's an offering what are you
oh my God look at our Glade this is the only way
and when the Grievers get what they came here for
oh we killed Galley now looking like Samwise gamji
over there do you hear me I said time off I mean
all right guys step up yeah there we go good good
good good good yeah nut kick get him sorry buddy
you don't have to come with us but we
are leaving anyone else who wants to
come that's your last chance just trying
to scare you no I'm not trying to scare
you you're already scared all right I'm
scared you have to be crazy not to be scared
come with us good luck against the gravers all
right you made your choice you take this Chuck
stay behind us we get out now but we die
trying get rich or die trying all right
good for Green Bay
oh it's all spooky how do you
fight it yes nice job guys
oh my God somebody stab it in the eye stab
it in the mouth yeah get its mouth come out
no no no no no under bits [Music]
no Chuck oh my god get it please get it
yes oh no oh no this is too much
[Music]
what [Music]
smart [Music] come on
[Music]
yell that last number out yes nice stab
what oh no oh poor guy
complete oh my goodness
oh bye bye scary spooky spider wow [Music]
oh gooey uh
well now we're just underground
walking through like to a concert
I feel like that's what it looks like
yeah yeah they'll be out in Sofi stadium
in just a second for the ears tour yeah we
remember those lights from his dream we do
yup very clearly the exit love that [Music]
oh no but the Grievers didn't get inside right
what if it was Thomas Theresa killed them all
maybe I gotta imagine Thomas was like this is
wrong we shouldn't do this and then they put
it in or something my name is Dr Ava page I'm
director of operations of the world catastrophe
Killzone Department what if you're watching this
that means you've successfully completed the maze
trials I wish I could be there in person to
congratulate you oh my it was all done for a
reason but the sun has scorched our world whoa
millions of lives lost to fire famine suffering
by global scale while warming this movie's woke
what came after it was worse we called it the
flare oh no a deadly virus that attacks the brain
it is violent unpredictable oh yeah in time a new
generation emerged that could survive the
virus suddenly there was a reason to hope
for a cure oh they're all those the young would
have to be tested all in an effort to understand
huh you realize it but you're very
important you're all the special
unfortunately your trials have only
just begun as you'll no doubt soon
discover not everyone agrees with her
methods the it may be too late for us
oh God remember she's getting
a shot right on camera
oh
that was 45 minutes ago
supposed to do now get out go outside oh God
they gotta walking in the scorched Earth okay
no no there he goes there he is Kelly don't
you can't leave oh there's no escape from this
place has he been out there has he seen
the world as it is I belong to the maze
what's Chuck thinking we all do oh
no damn oh that was a good faker
oh damn it no
yeah you're gonna kiss them yourself remember I
told you that you're gonna die
an old woman warm in your bed
I mean where did Chuck go I've
never seen him before he's good oh
who are these people coming in
legit bad about that
whoa okay into the sand on the outside of the
building I feel like it said Wicked did it
don't worry safe now what is going
on was that their their acronym
wckd yes Wicked are they saying
that their organization is good
oh yeah yeah okay oh my God I'd say Wicked shelter
oh my God I think it's safe to say the maze
trials were a complete success Thomas continues
to surprise and impress love that guy so
let's move forward it's time now to begin
phase two what is that what does that
mean what is the sequel called what
Grim world were all those scientists faking
dead because that means they had to fake
dead for a long time now to rig each other up
with squibs firing guns what in the tomorrow
their own lab exactly yeah break everything up
okay well this has just left me with a lot of
questions more questions what do you mean yeah
it's all wrapped up here Tara it's not James
Dashner only wrote One novel I assume I know
that's not true I'm gonna say I did not read
this book okay I had no idea what was going
on I thought at first maybe I did I did not
um this was intense I really liked it
yeah Galley was a real pain in the ass
uh which yeah I get it he was our like
he was playing playing the role but
um yeah I still have a lot of questions that um
went unanswered but I do think it's cool at the
end that you're like oh see I was like I was
this so they are kind of like clones but not
clones they're experiments and they're the
only ones who can survive the virus I guess
he messed up he messed up okay give
us give us the juice John what'd you
think I enjoyed it overall I mean yeah it's
definitely one of those movies that clearly
is setting up for much more uh lower and
many more twists and turns to come so like
yeah it's you know it ends fully on a note
of like oh we've just scraped the iceberg
um but yeah for the immediacy of what it was I
was always intrigued and I was always kind of
gripped by it I mean like you know you have this
very compelling Central mystery of like what's
in the freaking maze you know like what's what's
going on out there what does this all mean and so
I think a movie like this in certain ways uh
benefits greatly off that sense of mystery
and certainly by the end they do give you more
mystery to look forward to um but yeah I mean
it's one of those things where sort of like once
you're out you're like okay yeah so the monsters
were out there and then we just kind of had to
find the right uh you know sequence of mcguffins
and things and yeah and then we're able to break
it like it's it's more linear and straightforward
than it presents itself to be which is yeah like
it was going to be like a bait and switch like
you thought it was gonna have like more of a like
tricky reveal I thought it was gonna blow my mind
or something yeah and like it's cool like it's
I'm not like griping at it for not having like
some like amazing on expected twists right um
but yeah I mean like knowing again the lane
that this originates from and knowing that a lot
of those stories tend to be some kind of dystopian
apocalyptic Society maybe there's an ecological
angle like you know I mean all that stuff is kind
of fun and interesting as a reveal like oh the
Earth has been scorched and we gotta you know
like it's it begs a lot of questions in terms
of like okay so this is like a shelter thing but
they're running this game and it seems like part
of the game is Carnage and so like yeah it leaves
you with questions certainly which again is most
likely by Design it's one of those things where
I find myself wondering how the sequels will
play out and if they will deliver on getting
more interesting versus versus like you know kind
of laying groundwork right now or will it plummet
like will it fall into being like okay like here's
a dystopian sci-fi thing of like a bunch of young
people leading a resistance that I've you know
kind of seen a lot of times before yeah that we've
seen before yes like having the Maze and having
you know the isolation of like we're in the Glade
and like you know we can stay here everything's
fine or we can go out into this crazy unknown
Turf and uh and so without that you know I'm sure
they'll come up with something else I'm sure that
they're there's a reason why it's a popular series
yeah but yeah it kind of you know runs its course
for the maze itself and uh I don't know like
like Part of Me Maybe wish that we could have
seen some of the real like unknowns of the maze
yeah like I kind of thought right with the number
that was on the thing that or mixed with like
the maze numbers which yes that came in at the
end which we assumed but I kind of thought like
maybe it would be like a reveal like oh the way
for us to get out the secret is like us is like
uh us like the people that they would have had
I don't know especially with Thomas and Therese
like remembering they're the ones who remembered
stuff they came up at the end I get that they were
working on it smart like we kept doing here but
um I don't know I felt like there there would
be but I know the book's already written but
there would be like a reveal that like I don't
know that the secret was like in them and they
had to like figure figure more out I don't know
I I I did like I love the relationship between
um him and Chuck and I like that a lot uh I I
didn't get as sad as I think I maybe would have
because it's probably not enough time to really
build up his relationship with Chuck but in the
book I bet you there is right I would have cried
when Chuck died if I was reading the book but for
some reason it didn't it hit me trust me it did I
just didn't like it didn't hit me super hard like
maybe it could have if there was a little more of
a build up but um you got to get to the action so
I get it oh yeah and it's one of those like very
end sort of like Bleak World Stingers of like oh
and I thought that maybe there was going to be
some kind of Greater reveal with Gally maybe
that he was like the plant all along yeah making
sure they don't try they don't leave or maybe he
knows what's outside and he hasn't let on why like
he is so attached to being in the Glade but yeah
but yeah it mostly at least here in this execution
reads like ah we just need one more like you know
heart crushing sting of some sort to just remind
you that uh you know certain things are just too
good for this harsh world and Chuck is one of them
yeah I would have liked it if at the end if he had
remembered what was out there and how life was
shitty and he's like confessing that like it was
really hard for him out there and it sucked and
this is who I wants to be here and this is like
this is me reimagining the movie and he's crying
and he's like this is the only family I found is
here in this box you know and then they're like oh
man poor Galley he's just a jerk because he had a
hard life I don't know something like that yeah
it like and I'm sure I don't know I don't think
we'll get any more sort of expounding on that and
like again it's it's not a a major complaint of
mine because again part of the charm of a movie
like this is that you're just thrust into a
situation you don't know much about anybody but
yeah like for as much as that what like without
that becoming a moment of Greater personal
significance it does feel sort of like one
final gotcha because you know I mean true I don't
know I thought there could have been some kind of
Arc or some kind of thing with him where you know
it's like oh I was wrong or I followed you guys
out please you know like accept me or something or
please let me come along true like wait up for me
yeah I don't know like that I thought that that
yeah that that ending beat could have been more
rich in character stuff that would have made it
more feel a little less like a puppy killing yeah
you know that's true to make sure that you know
Thomas becomes that much more hardened next time
yeah and you know I mean like Teresa certainly
interesting presence not much of a character
that's like another thing that I'm like what the
heck like she was just like there and she came
with a note and then we didn't really give her
any more juice than that yeah and it's again I
know the the counter will probably be like well in
the sequel she's going to be a lot more important
yeah but yeah for the execution here if I only saw
this movie I would be like I kind of want to get
to know her a little bit better yeah um or you
know establish some kind of connection you know
because they have the whole thing about like we
know each other we used to work right across from
each other but it's it's only kind of a just one
of many details touched upon that's touched upon
and left in the like very quickly yeah and it's
like all the maze stuff is is cool the effects are
neat like the idea is really cool and I think
you know you can't make this like a two and a
half hour movie necessarily but you know it's once
you're on the other side of it I think it's that
it's like since they already have the whole place
mapped out I get the utility of that plot choice
but at the same time I'm like we could like learn
about I don't know because like we are we're doing
it through Dylan O'Brien's perspective but at the
same time I don't know it's it's pretty straight I
guess that's what I keep coming back to is like
for as much as this seems like straightforward
linear puzzle yeah it's pretty straightforward and
I think too it's like once he goes into the Maze
and figures it out you know what to kind of look
for and and you know kills the Reaver uh griever
and all that stuff you know that pretty much sets
you directly on the path whereas me I'm sitting
here going well there are like eight quadrants
they all must be different or are they all or or
you know is it just like any one of these could
have been the exit you know why is it that they
found the ones like they found number seven
first and number seven is the exit it's what
they thought about I thought they were gonna do
something like that where it's like oh it's just
the next level of the game but it's not the it's
not the exit and spiritually that's true because
at the end Patricia Clarkson's like you know I
wish I could tell you this is Dan but this is
just the beginning um but you know like we're out
into the world now so like I don't know the the
unless they're gonna prison break this and find
a way to maneuver them into a new Maze and this
is just a future that deals with its problems be
amazed it's just a scorched Earth with multiple
mazes on it and they just throw children in there
you're like good luck yeah and I thought you know
the the idea of the whole like Wicked is good
thing you know was an interesting Mantra to
kind of get you thinking about human nature
and then by the end you're like oh it must be
that you know this organization or the good guys
maybe and we shouldn't trust the people who are in
rescuing the kids right now right um but I don't
know this idea of like I thought that's what it
said on the outside was like Wicked uh shelter
shelter or something like that and and guys
wicked as their acronym was the world
they're funny like earmarks to be that do very
much again hearken to you know the fun of a
why a novel adaptation because yeah it's all
about it is good we got the cool terminology
all of our different lore that we're gonna set
up for you in a you know yeah and uh you know it
for an immediate I think I enjoyed the immediate
experience of this quite a bit and I enjoyed the
movie in hindsight once it was concluded look at
that was pretty good it was yeah it was fun and it
was you know intriguing but um it's gonna you know
like the sequel or whatever is gonna have to like
really kind of set itself apart from various other
like the world has been destroyed and working and
now we have to go yeah you know yeah like it
it's that I think is like the the early parts
of the movie have you going like this is really
fascinating and I'm not even thinking about other
stories like this and then when you get to the
end I'm like now I'm thinking of a lot of other
stories yeah yeah yeah it's true I feel like the
writer was like he was thinking about a phrase
that people would use after they read his book and
it's everybody who has the book and they're like
yeah you know that that's what they're doing
and like yeah I'm like oh that's probably their
inside thing like I'm surprised in 2014 I didn't
see like teenagers walking around with t-shirts
to say Wicked it's good but then I might have
been like you mean the musical or you know it
might have been confusing yeah or just you know
Boston slang again anyway I give it it means good
it means good and I'll give it I'll give it us
a seven out of ten what do you give it John lay
down 6.5 maybe because yeah we're probably in
the same spot I was gonna I was gonna go out
of five and say like you know three three and
a half like it's pretty good yeah pretty good
like I thought it was well assembled I thought
it was really I agree yeah like I thought the
performers all did a really nice job I thought
the way they you know established the world of
their Camp was really nice um I I liked a lot of
the details of how they were living and how they
shot a lot of this the intensity and just the way
they cap captured a lot of the effects and a lot
of the action sequences felt appropriately yeah
thrilling and harrowing and intense and whatnot
and again in you know when you're still deep in
the mystery I was really intrigued by that stuff
so I think like you know behind the camera there
was a lot of good work going yeah that's true um
and then yeah you know as a as an actual story you
know this is all right pretty good yeah I think
it's like I always think in my head I go to story
but then I was like oh man but those scenes with
the spiders like John's remember like remembering
it more than me but now I'm like I'm in it and I'm
like those were pretty dope those are awesome and
I'm like what are those things like yeah did you
guys make these for these trials or this is this
part of the immunity thing like you know did you
like capture a few mod them out and then you know
because this seems like it was all because of of
you know global warming weather catastrophes
yeah so what accounts for these creatures are
they purely yours is there something else that
work there again I'm sure we'll find out in his
sequel but we want to know now but yeah there are
ways in which this could have felt like a more
well-rounded Movie experience on its own yeah like
a more well-rounded story yeah yeah all right well
we did it we watched it we liked it we'll probably
next one and letting us know if we should watch
the next one I would also be happy to watch the
next one I mean we should just we should just do
it and then be like well we'll we'll all watch it
together we'll all decide but you guys should also
be like you should watch the next one but don't
do any spoilers in case we are going to yeah yeah
and what else do I say in closing John I want to
see react to other things I just told you about
um I think we're good I think you want to shout
out a patreon really quick before we get out of
here let's do that thing let's do it Anisa I'll
leave uh there's only one girl in the movie but
now you're the second well Tara's here too but
yeah you girls involved with the Maze Runner
experience today and if we were caught in the Maze
I would absolutely want you on our team because
you are a caring person but you're also a person
who knows your way around you know like health and
Medicine type things oh and also you're just the
kind of person who is tenacious you know if we had
to figure the maze out I feel like you would keep
us on track that would be good feeling good morale
High yeah and she'd also be able to heal wounds
or something yeah yeah that's good and if we found
out later that you were secretly involved with
you know like experimenting on stuff like I would
I would be willing to give you the benefit of the
doubt I would just kill you I mean also valid I'm
gonna have to protect you from Tara and that's
also what this shout out is for is just to let
you know you know that uh you should watch your
back too it's like man you were in there you were
doing experience with these spiders in the Maze
I'm like I'm not I know nope that's some BS like
you gotta go you know so whatever I guess when we
we're pushing you out into the maze now but keep
your Pledge on file because that's what really
this is all definitely keep it and if we ever
meet in person he's your buddy and I guess maybe
I'm not but if you're watching if we watch another
movie though and like we do another shout out ways
from now like it might be a different story with
you Anisa you know then we could be friends again
so you got to keep your patronage so like we can
see where our relationship goes friendship wise
you know I like that idea yeah that's a good idea
right maybe you'll come out of the other side as
friends yeah you never know kill me oh the other
side of the rainbow boom appreciate you we'll
see you there I love you Nisa love you bye peace